I was terrifying though too I mean this
the enemies chase you down
uh how hi welcome to this episode of
trash taste hope you enjoyed us trying
to order coffee we're not putting that
in
the patreon
no I guess uh do you feel like because
we're talking about ordering coffees now
I don't know why but when I have hot
coffee there's like a quote of like how
many hot coffees I feel comfortable
having in a day but as soon as it's hot
as soon as it's iced coffee I'm like oh
this is a different drink now
I don't know why it just feels like a
different drink because I never have
iced coffee unless it's in the summer
and to me it kind of feels like a
smoothie or something I wonder if that's
that's a no from me dog yeah and maybe
drinking this is the water droplets from
the ice diluting it making it taste less
coffee to me coffee shouldn't feel
refreshing you know coffee time coffee
feels too refreshing yeah a nice coffee
just feels too refreshing it's kind of
like that's how you know okay this is
literally the equivalent of being like
I'll drink a whiskey straight and I can
only do so many but when it's on Ice no
no no okay because I can go ahead
because because in a similar fashion to
me cocktails don't feel like alcoholic
drinks a lot of the times if a
cocktail's like you know you know the
ones I'm talking about I mean the ones
that taste like juice yeah that's right
the really fruity ones yeah so I gotta
go for the Gin tonic yeah I need that
kick
I'm drinking and drinking yeah
no because like I I'll drink a cocktail
and I'm like this it was a pleasant it's
like dessert yeah yeah it's so sweet and
like you can barely taste the alcohol a
lot of the time I'm like this is not
only is this the sugar bad for me yeah
the alcohol is like a double whammy like
I'm getting [__] exactly I'm like I'd
rather just well I mean that's why I
like it yeah that's why like if I when I
can if I'm at a bar and I'm like you
know we're in kind of a juicy fruity
cocktail kind of night all right
everyone's like drinking all the [__]
[__]
you've never invited me out on going
yeah with me yeah yeah God I'm feeling
like uh
the fruity cocktail yeah
when I can I try and double shot that
[__] because otherwise I it's just like
juice and I don't feel it it's like if
you drink like the whole night you know
where it's like I don't feel like I
drank no I I okay without you I still
feel like I can taste the alcohol three
percent okay I really like it it's yeah
it's fruit juice okay because here's the
thing here's here's how my mind works
right there's like sodas there's like
fruit juices and then there's [__] like
beer and wine right which I do I guess
like I like the taste of beer and wine
but that like portion of like me liking
that taste is different to me liking the
taste of juice and something that's
non-alcoholic when you add a cocktail
and stuff when you add a cocktail into
the mix that doesn't taste alcoholic my
mind registers it as juice right but the
problem is cocktails are normally like
triple or double the price of a beer or
a wine yeah and I finish it like way
faster yeah you ever gone to a cocktail
bar and it takes like 10 hours for like
the waiter to make this like really
elaborate cocktail yeah and then you
finish it in like one minute because it
tastes so good yeah but that's but
that's like I don't know cocktails are
not supposed to be like you're not
supposed to drink cocktails in the same
way you drink a juice and the terms like
oh yeah I can just get this whenever I
want so I can just [__] download
whenever I want or however fast I want
all right my [__] are supposed to be
like special you know I think there
should be a natural barrier uh and if I
can give this cocktail like a 10 year
old and he'll be like oh she does I'm
like that's a problem
so you want it to like taste like bare
minimum tastes like alcohol then you
should be there needs to be a an
indication of it that you like at the
moment I cannot taste the alcohol I feel
like I'm something about it is like that
is true I've drank some cocktails where
I'm like if I ordered the non-alcoholic
version or this it would taste exactly
yeah show me the treasure map because I
can't find it like for me I have a rule
if if it takes longer to make the drink
than it does for me to drink it then
that's not a drink I will like order
again in Japan there's so many bars that
do that where you know oh there's that
one bar that I always I reciprocal too
that I think yeah you've gone to I don't
know if you've gone too and there's
those guys and they're wearing like the
tuxedos yeah and they they take
literally 15 minutes to make a cocktail
what are they doing
basically and it's like this big and
it's so refreshing because you've been
waiting for so goddamn long for a drink
that's how they get you bro you drink it
in like five goddamn minutes you're like
so I can have another one
that's how they get you they're like
we'll wait until you're absolutely
parched so that when you order this girl
and you doubt it you want another one I
asked for a glass of water and obviously
it's a it's like a whiskey Place
normally yeah so they bring out like I
don't know why they bring out like the
tiniest shots of water and like this
like kind of vial it looks like
something you'd get like a like a
medicine and an RPG yeah and it's like
it's like Max like 50 milliliters and
I'm like what am I who what is it who's
this for the mice in the building all
right this is not we're gonna refresh it
or give me [__] what is this a Waterford
that's the one good thing about America
I'll give them credit you always get the
stupidest largest vessel uh of water
it's an incomprehensible amount of water
at every single restaurant or
establishment when you actually it's
never it's never smaller it's never like
a glass it's like prepare for the slump
jug 5 000 800 milliliters of straight
water and ice in your veins yeah like
you can keep a goldfish in there yeah
for sure
um so that's one problem the Japanese uh
bars need to fix it's kind of like we're
looking at it though on like both ends
of the spectrum really it's like Japan
is like way too Little America in my
opinion Europe way too much yeah yeah
Europe gets it right in the middle I
feel yeah anyway the point being is that
cocktails are nice but I don't want to
eat them a lot of the time so I drink
them I used to eat them I was thinking
about a different point in my head it
was like how like I don't know why but
it makes when I order a cocktail it
activates the same part of my brain that
when I eat a brownie
and the ice cream's on the side
I'm like did we really need the ice
cream like I feel like I was I felt bad
about ordering the brownie already
because it's so [__] bad for me and
then you just did like a giant [__]
scoop of vanilla on the side and I felt
like I didn't really need it and I I
just it activates the same part of my
head where it's like sugar more yes
please yeah but sometimes you order a
brownie from a restaurant that thing is
like dry it's like drywall like that's
how it's a bad brownie if I gotta rely
on that yeah but that's why they pair
with the [__] ice cream so I decide
that [__] that's true yeah the the only
place that I actively like ordering
cocktails like like this this is the
only place because I just figured out
now that I'm older I've just lost
the [__] out Connor but you want to
juggle woo-woo for 12 weeks honestly
like two like a jug for 12 quid or
something or like
it is
I think it's gone up now but you used to
be able to get like two jugs as well for
like 12. damn but that's the thing I I
allow those because those are like
shitty enough cocktails yeah but you can
taste the alcohol right is it weird that
I want to taste the alcohol not because
I specifically like the taste of alcohol
but if I'm drinking this drink for the
specific purpose of getting drunk I like
my brain to remind it that you know I am
getting drunk at this point I don't
think you guys are thinking too hard to
like min max alcohol
I just feel like cocktails are this
weird cheat code area we figured out
yeah yeah and I feel like we're defying
the laws of nature yeah because because
playing God with cocktails it's our
natural warning when we drink something
with alcohol where it's like oh body's
like no no don't drink this yeah but we
do it anyway yeah but I need that
reminder yeah because like for me like
for me it's important like for me one of
the only place like with all the
cocktails is like buy a pool side or on
the beach or something when it's like a
nice pina colada because in my mind I'm
just like oh today's a cheat day you
know I I get to I get to order on
vacation I'm on vacation mode I get to
order dessert at like lunch time yeah
that's the first thing you're upset it
is if it's a British thing or if you
just like you know
we're on the beach yeah oh we're on the
beach right
but yeah like to me like have you guys
been recommended like these like I don't
know sometimes you go on like YouTube
shorts and there's just like this a lot
of cocktail videos yeah the guy who does
like the Russian guys aesthetic looking
cocktails that I've never thought that
ice could just like look so pretty and
now I'm just like oh that ice was frozen
uh that was that's completely clear ice
no bubbles zero buttons that must have
like exactly who you talking you know
who I'm talking about in Japan they
always go so hard with that oh yeah ice
the ice game is impeccable here it is
you'll hear him going away at it for
like 15 minutes yeah perfectly you know
it's going to be a good cocktail when
you order a cocktail and the first thing
the master does is bring out a giant
block of ice and a huge knife and you're
like oh [__] oh yeah it's happening
you're so nice man getting cozy and like
I there's a bar I go to quite a lot uh
whenever I want to go out to drink with
people the guy's so chill he's so nice
yeah one dude runs it plays smooth jazz
and it's just one dude and then one time
this is where I felt like we'd we buy
bonded in a weird way I was like hey can
I borrow your charger and he was like of
course bro he gave it to me and I was
like it's a real one it's a real one
right there
that's some real friends like you borrow
their charge I'm coming back
this is like I said there's a weird
thing about people like not wanting to
let people use like electrical sockets
or use like electricity of a business I
don't know it depends like they're just
really chill about it I feel I feel most
of those like small bar places they're
best friends now yeah I feel a lot of
the small bar places they don't really
care but if it's like you know a an
establishment where it's like they're
trying to make money they're trying to
make this business lucrative then
they're like oh I mean you could borrow
my charger and uh you know put me up an
extra 50 handle my electricity bill but
you should probably order three
cocktails first it's like okay that
doesn't seem fair but first one drink
they just don't want to be in there yeah
I just want you to order a drink drink
it get the [__] I think it's just
asking for any requests that's off the
script of the Japanese menu you know and
I I guess I guess that's just true for a
lot of establishments in Japan where
there's not a lot of better menus yeah a
lot of bars like what do you want no I
mean like bars are different like asking
for asking for a request that's off like
what they have listed in their mental
checklist area and you asked like oh can
I borrow the charger the waitress would
probably be [__] herself well it's
like this is not I did not learn yeah
what to say in this situation you can
literally see them like socially blue
screen yeah just like oh once you hear
that then you know this is a blue screen
yeah yeah I kind of realized how much
I'd forgotten I'd like kind of like
taken just like that kind of like little
thing for granted until I go to a place
outside of Japan like I remember in
Australia
uh this was I think like last year when
uh we were flying back or something and
I'd stayed like a few extra days to stay
with family
uh I had booked so we're in Melbourne
and I had booked a plane uh not from
Melbourne Airport uh Melbourne Airport
but I did not know the difference
between Melbourne Airport and I think
Avalon is that like the other
there's one main airport yeah and then
there's one in the [__] ton like middle
of nowhere yeah where you have to drive
like two hours or some [__] like yeah
it's a domestic airport yeah it's a
domestic airport I didn't know I just
chose an airport right uh and I didn't
know that this was the shitty airport
that basically only I think Jetstar or
something like yeah fly out there
and so I didn't know that
and so what happens is I had like uh I
had a I had a SIM card which was my
British SIM cards uh so he could receive
texts but the data was a little bit
spotty right welcome to Australia yeah
welcome to Australia so we I was in this
[__] Uber
um driving to this airport that was an
hour out we were 45 no we're like
halfway there
right and it was the only flight flying
to Sydney that day
I don't know why I thought there would
be more flights flying to Sydney that
day and uh halfway to this airport I get
a text being like your flight has been
canceled and I'm like
[__] what what am I supposed to do I'm
like halfway to this airport
uh I don't have a flight there that I
know there's not going to be any other
flights there so I've just gotta go back
to the city so I like tell the Uber
driver hi I notice I know it's really
bad but can you turn around and uh drop
us off back uh you know back in
Melbourne and we'll figure it out there
and he's like sure all you need to do is
just add in a new destination uh on the
Uber app yeah problem is I got no data
yeah I can make and receive calls but I
got no data yeah yes like welcome to
welcome to the 21st century if you don't
have internet you are [__] yeah uh and
I'm like [__] what can I do so we saw
like I saw like [__] panicking
because he's like I cannot I cannot
change the destination on my app you
have to be the one to change the
destination uh so I'm like okay let's uh
let's look for a place that might have
free Wi-Fi not knowing forgetting that
uh outside of major cities Australia
there's no internet Australia is
apparent Wasteland that has no [__]
internet so so I'm trying to look for
like a rest stop or something and we're
driving for like another like 10 minutes
thankfully we see a convenience store I
think it's a I think it was like a
7-Eleven yeah uh and I'm like [__] [__]
[__] I'm hoping that Japan like
Australia is kind of like Japan or
America where they have public Wi-Fi at
every [__] convenience store like
public
no no
they do in Japan really they do in Japan
in a lot of places well you have data in
Japan yeah like every parking area has
like free Wi-Fi yeah I don't know that
yeah so we pull up to the 7-Eleven and I
go up to the cashier I'm like uh mate do
you have uh do you have a like public
Wi-Fi here and he's like what's Wi-Fi
yeah and he's like sorry mate like we
don't have we don't have Wi-Fi here and
I'm like [__] I'm in kind of a bind
right now and like I explained my
situation and he's like oh no worries
I'll start tethering all my fun I've got
I got data here and I'm like [__]
hell I've forgotten I'd forgotten what
this feeling was like being like hey you
forgot that people are helpful yeah I'm
like hey I'm in a bind I know how I have
a strange request right now but uh do
you have any public Wi-Fi because I'm
kind of [__] if uh if you don't uh and
he's like don't worry mate I got you
covered I don't like [__] this this has
never happened to me in Japan where I'm
just in a bind and you have a request
that's kind of like out of left field
and uh people actually respond to that
and uh we'll try to help you what if you
just will [__] you with him he's like
hold on I gotta like these tweets first
all right oh yeah oh yeah yeah right
right there yeah that's right yeah so
thank you 7-Eleven person like random
Seven and Seven Eleven person in
Melbourne you are yeah you saved me
literally like two hours of my life
why don't you go to the normal Apple
there's like it's like a flight to
Sydney every like two minutes because uh
when I booked it I didn't know that
there were two words also why did you
not ask the Ubi driver if you could
borrow his tether
[Music]
that was a reason why he couldn't tether
and I can't remember why because he was
driving maybe but I did ask him because
I I'm like I tried to go through every
engineering route to solve this issue
and I can't remember the reason why he
couldn't tether but yeah he couldn't
feel like maybe he was an [__]
I want the uh full charge for me going
to this airport then going back yeah
there was uh yeah because like I think
it's really normal for some reason that
flights between Melbourne and Sydney get
canceled or delayed well if from regular
Melbourne Airport they this is like a
flight that leaves every 30 minutes yeah
even if it does get canceled it's not a
big issue I mean Kai was sitting in the
like Lounge waiting and there was like
six flights in the next like three hours
yeah and like half of them got canceled
yeah and I there's like no explanation
why yeah and so I think ours got pushed
back and it made my transfer really
tight made it from like an hour and a
half to like 30 minutes and I was like
oh I don't I don't really feel like
risking it and there's a flight coming
up in like 40 minutes and I was like
well let's go ask if I can go on that
one I was like hey can I just go on this
flight and they were like yeah I was
like oh
they're all like yeah oh okay cool
thanks so I went on that flight
I literally just went up and I was like
hey uh I got a tight connection I just
go on the one that's coming up in like
20 minutes yeah that would never happen
in Japan no yeah what did you take a say
it says [__] no
yeah it like really surprised me in
Japan that you even have to like book
out shinkansen tickets like and if you
don't have the sometimes you know so the
shinkansen is like split up so that like
the first I think three cards are like
free so basically if you buy a ticket
for that day you can go on any Shing
content that takes you to your
destination it's just if there's a seat
you can grab the seat if there's no seat
you have to stand up and then the rest
of it is all yeah booked yeah that's all
well the Japan uh Japan uh rail passes
all those get those two so right we're
kind of competing against people who
haven't booked and also tourists right
so it's kind of tough because I think
the on some really busy routes you're
really very hard to get a chair yeah
sometimes last minute I've gotten those
tickets and like there's been a couple
of occasions where I've had to wait like
a station or two to just like wait for a
seat to open up so I'm just like
chilling I'm always I've always just
gone to the thing the uh machine yeah
and even if because even if the Train's
in like five minutes I'll just still get
the reserve team yeah yeah cause you can
just you can just get a ticket easily
and sometimes during busy times of the
year there's no yeah
can you get a ticket really easily I
don't know well there's there's one
there's one trip up about the shinkansen
that kind of [__] people a lot um and
it's it's not explained well at all so
you can buy The Limited fare ticket yes
which is like the first part of the
ticket yes but then if you want to get a
seat you have to buy another ticket yeah
and it's yeah for some reason they allow
you to buy the seat without buying the
limited fare ticket yeah I think it's
because of like the rail passes and
stuff yeah so you can ease very easily
accidentally buy the ticket seat think
that you have a ticket go to the gate
and then you won't be able to get
through yeah and then some guy will have
to awkwardly explain to you hey no you
got to go and buy this other ticket
you've only bought half the ticket yeah
I mean Japan Japan train system great
Japan train ticketing system it is the
booking anything in Japan it is the Dark
Souls boss of getting anywhere because I
have missed like especially now that you
know family and friends have come round
uh that I've I've now missed like at
least at least three Like Trains because
because of the ticketing system yeah we
arrive especially in a big group they
don't know obviously they don't know the
ticketing system and even me knowing the
ticketing system and knowing there's a
difference between like the limiting
Express and the limited one and
sometimes you can buy one and not the
other sometimes you just use suika and
not the other I'm going up there and I'm
like there are some times where I'm like
I am wasting at least 15 to 20 minutes
getting especially if that's like a big
group yeah you you are wasting at least
like 15 to 20 minutes with that you have
to like factor in and if you don't get
the tickets in time you just straight up
miss the [__] train yeah yeah that's
right if I go with a big group I just I
book it for everyone yeah I book it
online I get the tickets yeah I'll book
mine on the speaker because you can book
it to your circuit yeah you can pick on
the speaker crazy convenient because you
can use that boop I'm in boys
no worries you can just tap in right
away yeah because sometimes I remember
when Sid's parents were here uh I booked
a train and it was a group of like at
the time it was like at least like seven
seven of us and getting a return ticket
for a trained do you know how many
[__] tickets that is yeah it's like
14 days
yeah you so sorry like I paid for it all
at once I got like 14 [__] tickets
and the receipts yeah right and we we we
we we had like 10 minutes being like
okay which one which one is the uh which
one's the one going out and which one's
return and whose is who and it doesn't
give you it in order either yeah so it
is it is a [__] nightmare getting
tickets in Japan well one thing I
learned about Japan and you maybe
correct me if I'm wrong on this there is
you do not save any money from buying a
return ticket not supposed to buying you
don't individually yeah unless it's like
you're coming back or going in a really
busy period where like you know because
like usually during like holidays it
goes up a little bit and like you know
depending on availability on the Train
sometimes like last minute tickets can
go up a little bit but like even then
it's like an extra [__] 10 20 bucks
yeah most I mean again I could be wrong
on that but from my so I always booked
the train going out and then coming back
I just I just rock up and I just buy the
ticket when I get there because it's
just like I don't want to deal with oh
no I'm my my shoot over ran oh I
finished early or whatever I'm just like
I'd rather just leave when I when I want
to leave yeah yeah exactly that's great
yeah I love the trains
trains are great as long as I don't have
to deal with the ticket machine if I
don't have to deal with the ticket
machine normally it's a very very good
experience I like the UK trains though
too I like the open return I do I great
you can just get a ticket open return
you take whatever [__] train you want
yeah and then you have one month the
moment you said that God like looked
over listen listen I I think the open
return is [__] sick it's a small
thing the one thing about it the one
thing about the shinkansen uh which you
have to appreciate is that it's ungodly
expensive yeah it is very expensive
sometimes it's more expensive than
taking a flight uh normally always yeah
normally always but that you have the
convenience of not having to travel all
the way to a [__] airport and go
through all that [__] yeah yeah with
like a one-way ticket to
uh Kyoto or Osaka is normally a hundred
bucks yeah at most and you know normally
you can get return flights for less than
that if you want to but I mean also you
should always hit the bullet train
there's better like you know if you're
going Beyond Osaka or Beyond not like
north of Japan you're pretty better off
flying yeah yeah like most [__] Chris
one time we're going to support her for
a video and Chris was hell-bent on
taking the train there and I was like
why are you why you want to take the
train he's like I just think it would be
much more enjoyable we can get more work
done and for some reason I let him
convince me into doing it and I was like
let's just shut [__] [__] four and a
half hour train that was ungodly
expensive to hakudate and then we had to
wait around for an hour and then another
hour and a half training mind you guys
the shinkansen does not go to Sapporo
there's like a there's like a huge
distance between Supra and the last stop
yeah meanwhile the [__] flight we can
go to Canada our flight yeah it's like
it's like a 200 bucks each I believe
Chris kept managed to convince you I
can't believe he convinced me he was he
was pretty adamant about it and I was
like all right fine and then I did it
once now and I've I've constantly told
him that I've never done doing that ever
again yeah the only time that shinkansen
is worth it is if you're actually going
to talk without you how could that they
show because you can get like the one
thing I always tell people to experience
if they want to splurge a little bit uh
because it's by far the best route to do
it because the the the trains in Japan
they're run by two different companies
one that goes west towards uh um like
all soccer Kyoto one that goes and the
one that goes north but they're not
called north and west it's the Jr East
Jr West but but the shinkansen's they
use are different uh in each area so
they're like I think uh Kyushu has one
or two shinkans that they're like their
own version there's not much difference
um but the the north one they have the
the grand class right which is like
really bougie and fancy you pay like an
extra hundred bucks but you get like
your own server on the train and drinks
and stuff so and like so basically
business class of Shane constant pretty
much so when when like uh Ludwig and and
uh some of the odd boys came I was like
yeah I should try it because we're going
to hugger that day yeah we may as well
try it we basically had the whole cart
to ourselves and you get the food and
the street and it was nice it was good I
just forgot my headphones so it's four
and a half hours off silence
I can't believe I have to talk to my
friend no no no no they hold they all
had headphones
have fun in your silence Solace yeah you
did the equivalent of forgetting to
think bring your phone when you're about
to take [__] you know it's just like
what do I do now what do I do with my
life sorry I don't know that was I mean
it was great but I I I you know if you
you want to splurge a bit of money you
just get it one way it's kind of it's a
fun experience to try and the chairs are
very nice this episode is sponsored by
expressvpn using the internet without
expressvpn is like writing an important
report and forgetting to hit save have
you ever had that hey most of the time
you'll probably be fine but what if one
day your computer freezes or crashes and
all your hard work is gone oh my God for
us absolutely no man you bring me back
Joey oh my God that's why we use
expressvpn every time you connect to an
unencrypted Network cafes Hotel airports
any hacker on the same network can gain
access to your personal data be that
password or financial data and we're on
tour right now so that would be awful we
have to connect to a lot of different
Hotel routers and Wi-Fi networks and you
know a lot of those aren't safe most of
the time and it doesn't take much
technical knowledge to hack someone just
some cheap Hardware is needed a smart 12
year old could do it even Conor could do
it I could do it even Joey could do it
and don't forget that your data is
valuable hackers coming up to one
thousand dollars per person selling
personal info on the dark web expressvpn
uses an encrypted tunnel to create
secure encrypted tunnels between your
device and the internet making it so
that hackers can't steal your sensitive
data and it's super secure as well guys
so secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com trashtaste
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-svpn.com
slash trash taste and you can get an
extra three months free expressvpn.com
trash taste back to the episode have you
ever been on any of those like fancy
trains in Japan like dude you went on
the sleeper trainer yeah that's not
[__] fancy [__] it's a bed it's [__]
it's not worth it what was better the
tour bus or the Sleepy train tour bus
100 oh are you serious no no no no doubt
probably you have to bear in mind like
the the sleeper train the worst part
about the sleeper train is that
um at least the one I got you I could
have chose a better route but there was
it was first of all impossible to book
yeah impossible I it I you you cannot
fathom how [__] this website is this is
the single shittest website I've ever
seen in my life it does not work flat
out and then
I had to get two Japanese people to help
me figure out this goddamn website and
it took but all three of us [__]
around on this website trying different
inputs to get this thing to work because
if you put one wrong input you have to
go all the way back you can't press the
back button you have to restart all the
inputs type the station you could you
have to say the exact time you want so
you can't look at all the trains you
have to put a time in and if there's not
a train at that time nothing will show
up it won't say hey by the way in two
hours another train which is insanitive
it's insane so you just have to know
what time the train is yeah and then on
top of that
um it's it's all booked out constantly
because trying to attackers in Japan run
it they run the show you don't have a
chance yeah competing against them sure
um and then so it will tell you like hey
there's free carts in this train on this
website and you click it and then you
open it and it'll say there's no cards
and you're like what and it'll be like
luxury normal standard and they'll say
like all sold out but then you click on
like the X where it says it's all sold
out and you open a drop down menu and be
like Oh but there is two and it's like
psychotic
[Music]
with like that X knowing I had to go
through all that just to get on the
train yeah and then you get on the train
and we got on at like 11 p.m and then at
5 a.m or 6 a.m I start just blasting the
announcements of all the stations yeah
and so it's kind of hard to get in your
sleep and you know you've got to get off
the train at like eight yeah so you're
on this train at 11. ideally you're not
shooting a video like we were and you're
in bed right away
um but even then it's small it's crap
it's kind of hot and stuffy right I wish
the boss was way better
I will say the one the one really really
cool thing about the super train and it
is the best part about it is that like
just lying down and like waking up and
then having this awesome window you can
just watch through it is really cool for
like two hours of sunlight you get yeah
I I can understand why there is kind of
like a train culture in Japan like not
not just like you know train culture
I'll take my coffee by the way okay
we'll take we'll take the coffees Now
give me my desserts they arrived and uh
I just wanted to [__] around find it uh
I ordered the oats milk one right yeah
don't worry guys they're cold they're
not good enough this is this this
doesn't count towards one of the coffees
I'm drinking even though it definitely
is a coffee but not like I've only had
like
I would say a I wouldn't call it like a
positive train experience but like I
kind of like a aha moment where train
rides can be really like kind of like a
really cool experience and the only time
I've had that is in Japan
um because to me like trains have always
been kind of like cars they're like a
tool to get me from point A to point so
I mean going from Brighton to London was
one of the somehow shittest Journeys oh
it's [__] [__] so I think that also
doesn't help the fact that you had to
always do that yeah that was a terrible
Journey yeah yeah but uh you know uh me
and Cindy had a little bit of like a
vacation in like the Izu prefecture
recently and to get to the easy
prefecture yeah we use the train and the
train goes all around the coastline of
like of like Southern Japan and it is
the most beautiful train ride I've liked
is that the romance car that is not the
romance car goes to uh
yeah the romance he's got loads of that
too yeah it's all the trains go around
the app on the outskirts yeah and like
it happens to be like a [__]
beautiful day in the in the summer not
the summer in Spring before it was like
too [__] hot uh and you just saw like
the mountains and the seaside and I'm
like holy [__] this is so [__]
beautiful and I get to experience this
just like going from point A to point B
you know I'm like and then it was on
this it was on this train ride that we
saw like we saw the we saw this [__]
hogwarts-ass looking train on this like
on the train track go past us and we're
like what the [__] is that I've got what
it's called but there is like a specific
train an SL sorry an SL what's an SL
likes uh this uh [__] steam line or
something like it's it's the steam
trains right there's a few luxury trains
right yeah yeah it's kind of you're
trying to get on them yeah yeah it's
it's kind of like one of these like
luxury trains it looks like it's like
come straight out of Hogwarts uh it
doesn't look like any of like the modern
trains that you see yeah uh and we just
saw like a bunch of people just having a
meal and just it's kind of like those
old like railway trains you see in like
the like early America yeah yeah where
you know old like oil tycoon type type
people just sit down and just like be
served at high class meal and stuff
oh but uh yeah I didn't know those
Services exist in Japan and uh we looked
into it and there are a lot yeah there's
a ton there's one in Hokkaido that Chris
went on on journey across Japan and it
was like it was just one train that runs
for that day across like the central
Hokkaido and the seats are [__]
impossible to get yeah from the outside
it's straight up just looks like a
Hogwarts trains yeah like people always
like oh man I want to go and go on this
train I'm like good luck you you can't
compete against these trainer talkers
they they again like I said they run it
yeah they just run it they know more
than you they care more than you they
they're on the website they know exactly
when it's going up you you are not out
competing these guys Lord knows I've
goddamn tried
um I've been trying to get tickets to go
on the Kyushu one for ages uh and I just
not only is that website again terrible
and impossible to navigate maybe that's
the barrier you know it is but like I I
got a I got a friend to call them up and
they were like yeah we will uh we will
release information about tickets soon
didn't say when didn't say [__] of
course the train attackers know when
it's going up somehow they always know
because they've got like a they got like
friends and they're telling each other
yeah
yeah it's like the Inner Circle yeah
yeah I'm like I can't ah it's unfair let
me write the goddamn train I want to go
on the Seven Stars and Kyushu you're not
a trainer talking I'm not I'm not you're
not fit for it dude I realize that like
that built death because presumably you
know the sleeper train there's there's
like multiple every day and we were at
one at like 11 50 p.m and it was like
the paparazzi came out to watch these
two trains doc yeah yeah it's crazy
there was like 40 people with dslrs
going like
of watching these two trains just like
Doc like like this and then everyone's
like oh
a couple of them definitely nodded when
they saw it yeah
this was this was dojin to them you know
but I don't need porn
I remember watching a YouTube video in
Japan about this I think it was Seven
Stars and Q shoes around there's just a
guy who had like he made his own fan
club for the train oh [__] sake what
the mozzie bite me on the lip yeah yeah
for [__]
I've been scratching it and I'm like why
is the bump disappeared on my lip I
don't think it was there at the
beginning of this episode we can check
that I think it's just been forming I
haven't done those yet yeah
so this guy had made a one-person fan
club for like this train what one person
oh I think he would rock up to every
time the train would leave yeah
I just had a rubber band that flew
somewhere around it's right there
he made it so he would turn up every
single time the train departed with like
a banner and stuff and be there like
train fan club and I'm like man that's I
wish I got that much joy from just
seeing a train I wish I'm always so fast
I'm so jealous of them yeah I've always
just been curious I I want to get into
something you know I feel I feel like
it's cool to have like one weird kind of
like passion and hobby that you just
like I don't know I I just don't know
how and I wish I knew the mechanics of
the brain of how the Joy works there
like how that's what I want to know how
did you see oh it's like I've seen this
train leave the station every time just
make you happy well yeah but I want to
know but those well those same guys are
probably looking at us you know [__]
ourselves with the chainsaw man Trail
I'm being like yes there to get excited
yeah maybe they get they think like
going out drinking yeah I understand
that did you did you never go through a
train phrase when you were like a kid
yeah I do no
what everyone loves trains as a kid are
you kidding I had like I had like I love
training I had like a I had like a PC
game that my uncle bought me and it just
like I had Pokemon right you guys had
Pokemon yeah yeah how the [__] could
train
Pokemon this is before like I had just
gotten like memory like image permanence
or like yeah whatever I was like two or
three yeah what the [__] you remember
anything from that no way you remember
two or three years I remember my my dad
old mom had
this was like a train like shinkansen
Simulator game yeah that came with like
a periphery of like the controls for the
train and I remember playing that as
like a two or three year old being like
I'm gonna be a train conductor some of
my earliest memories are trains I don't
know why like I don't know why but like
had like man's greatest invention okay
okay here actually yeah what are some of
like your earliest memories like you can
remember what's like the first memory
ever remember I have this memory my mum
loves to bring it out to people okay um
I think we were playing one time me and
my brother were playing with like a
wooden train set very like old style
thing
um and I don't know what happened but
there was this like there was a you were
into trains I was playing with trains
what do you mean bro everyone you were
just given trains but I was not into
them I was not like mothers but you
remember it you remember only because my
mum kept bringing this up for the rest
of my life
um there was you know they had like a
tunnel a wooden tunnel that would go
over the train track
sugoi the train disappeared yeah and
then it came back out whoa yeah uh
I think my older brother had knocked my
train over yeah so my response was to
just grab this wooden tunnel and just
slam him in the head
my mum just thought oh my God this what
is wrong with this kid he's so violent
so that was how I got into Doom
so that's when I didn't uh that's when I
went past my train face yeah yeah I see
if the train phase went to my violence
yeah and then also another core memory I
have from my youngest I think I was very
very young I think I've told the story
on trash taste I might have
um we have one of those punching bags
and I told the story I think I have
right it's a punching bag filled with
like water or sand at the bottom oh yes
yes and it came back and smacked you in
the face no no I was punching it as a
kid yeah and I was punching it and I was
like ah yeah yeah punching it goes back
up yeah yeah yeah and I'm I'm laughing
on my mum's screams it turned out my
thumb had been all the way backwards
from me
[Music]
I just had this cool memory of me
looking at my hand and going like
a home alone [__] skit uh yeah I
can't remember how it got back what's
your earliest memory well I think I've
already said my earliest memory on trash
case which is getting stung in the eye
by a bee oh yeah uh that that was a cool
memory and I'll never forget the pain of
that but that's just trauma yeah that's
just that's just trauma but aside from
that like some core memories uh
that are like the earliest memory are
literally to do with trains it's it was
so such a simple joy because there would
be there'll be a train crossing yes it
is very interesting isn't it
yeah there'll be like a train crossing
on the on the drive home from like my
restaurant to like my house and I think
my dad would purposely like I think
before I had like real image permanence
I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure my dad will I drive
around in circles because it just like I
because I just have this core memory of
like being on the crossing and it's
already for some reason I was always at
the front of the crossing and my dad's
like train coming train and then I it's
almost like my neurons were just forming
because every time I saw a train I would
go train train see it disappear and then
just be like I can't remember what
happened afterwards like the Train the
CH like all my core memory is just
seeing a train appear seeing it
disappear then I don't remember what
what came next you know but that's
usually I remember this happening so
many [__] times when I was a kid so
it's almost like just like seeing a
train as a kid just fired up neurons in
my brains you know this is how I gained
image like a part of God's mind being in
his 30s now just every time he sees the
train just in his head he's just like
Trey yeah
maybe some people should just never grew
out of that you know maybe maybe that's
a train or tacos yeah yeah that's it
that's it they are that kid where at the
age of three they're going trainship
at the going train it's like that monkey
with like the neuron activation like
slime that's what happens when they see
train just like neurons activating so
you've got to have that thing everyone's
gotta have a thing
what do you mean gotta have a thing
everyone's gonna have a thing like a
thing they like yeah of course because
it's got a hobby right yeah yeah and
some people's uh trains yeah you know
another cool memory I have I I remember
the first time I saw a rainbow actually
that's that's a I don't know why that
was a double rainbow all the way I
remember the exact point I saw my first
rainbow and that was I think happened
right after I saw a train
he was a train with a rainbow on top
yeah I think things set on trains are
inherently cool I think so something
cool about being on a train there is
yeah something I don't know as a kid
there's something just fascinating about
trains and like [__] ambulances and I
I know for a fact at least for me
because like where I grew up we had no
[__] trains whatsoever our closest
train station was like a 30 to 35 minute
drive away right so just the concept of
trains to me just in my local area was
just unheard of yeah so I think that's
why as a kid I got so into trains
because there was that disparity between
being in Australia not ever going on a
single [__] train to going to Japan
where every day you are on a train yeah
so like having a childhood like that for
me just made me be like yeah trains are
sick
exit on the right side will open hell
yeah say it again yeah please did you
ever like fire engines uh fire trucks as
a kid just the engine so the [__] is
this episode
it's like diapers
I'm just okay
helicopters
actually though I don't know I'm just
trying I guess I'm trying to
psychoanalyze myself be like why the
[__] did so many kids I know including
me just like fire trucks if you like
fire trucks yeah 90 probably you buy
so my experience with a fire truck was
when we were I think like first or
second grade we had like a school
Excursion when we went to like a fire
department yeah to learn about like fire
safety and she's like I'm pretty sure
most schools go through this [__] but
that was the first time like I had seen
a fire truck and they were like you can
hold the hose if you want and I was just
like okay I already got hers
yeah I don't know if I ever is yeah I
don't know as a kid a [__] vehicle
where that spouts out water fight fire
and make some
is there anything [__] cooler maybe
helicopter I will say hey yeah
helicopter okay I remember I remember my
sister when she was like four years old
for a school presentation she was like
what do you want to be when you grow up
and she's like I want to be a fire truck
not a fire fighter no because he was in
Japanese and like firefighter is sure
[__] and fire truck is sure more
sharp so she accidentally said I want to
be a fire truck and we all thought like
you [__] idiot maybe she's one of the
Optimus Prime
I want to be that whatever that is the
all spark uh I I um have you noticed
that in Japan uh people like the fire
trucks and ambulances are way too polite
yeah like they're really slow about it
in America I feel like they're like
balls to the wall get the [__] out of it
it's your fault in the UK I feel like
people are way too slow to get out of
the way here for them
everyone's very cautious I would say so
I guess that's everything and we don't
want anymore well I yeah because I see
sometimes how slow some of these like
ambulances and fire trucks are like you
know cutting through red lights and [__]
I'm like is that really is there really
an emergency happening or did you just
want to like get home quickly like I
think it's the emergency Joey I can't
because sometimes they they're going
slower than regular cars on a green
light so I'm like are you like in a
hurry at all or like is this building
just like gone at this point now and you
just like come into the after cleanup
like what's what's going on like I feel
like you should be in a little bit more
of a hurry especially ambulances oh my
God yeah they feel so slow they're so
slow
would not want to be in the middle of
nowhere with an ambulance I mean I I
feel bad whenever when I lived in
Thailand and it was like a lot of
traffic and then I'd hear the ambulance
and I'd be like
rest in peace
I'm sitting here in traffic and like
people are trying their best to make way
for this ambulance but there is I mean
there are there are already like four
lanes in this road and there are five
Lanes of cars in this road there is no
space for the cars to move I think it'd
just be quicker for the paramedics to
run over you know
honestly it would definitely be quicker
so cars are moving out the way but it's
it's like it's it is still snail's pace
yeah I've seen fire trucks try to get
through traffic in Bangkok as well that
is that is ashes uh bulldozers on the
front of them
you're moving you don't have a choice I
feel like they'd have a better chance
just hiring an army of like motorcycles
with like buckets of water and one fire
engine to drive through like Bangkok
traffic
let's deploy the helicopter if your car
got bulldozed out of the way
everyone would move I mean suddenly they
wouldn't have a choice they'd stop
tetrising cars in the street they'd be
like guys uh parking here oh the
L-shaped
carry changing topics though
has have you ever fallen out of love
with let's say a hobby or something you
like because of a fan base
because uh anime yeah
um yeah I want to say fallen out of love
I would definitely say like not be as
vocal about it it's probably the more
correct way I like I am I am getting to
a breaking point now because
[__] one-piece fans man I I
don't know what's happening I don't know
when this is when this has started to
happen yeah because like to me like when
I grew up with One Piece One Piece was
always like the least popular like a
sleeper hit yeah the sleeper one out of
like bleach and now it was the most
chill out of it you know one piece fans
were like the most chill because
everyone was like yo Naruto yo bleach
and one piece fans are like yo we
just just ignore the art style don't
worry it's a really good story just get
to it
and now
at this current point in time I feel
like one piece fans are becoming the new
Dragon Ball fans oh I and by the time
this episode is getting released I'm I'm
I am going to Hazard a guess that they
have fully transformed into the new
Dragon Ball fans do you know why that
happened though because there's no
Naruto in Bleach equivalent to keep them
harmful
I think whenever a show hits a level of
popularity it just happens though
yeah I mean there's it's it is a level
of proper popularity but I feel like
they are getting so [__] insufferable
now and I feel like a lot of this is
around the uh I mean this is probably
the most spoiled [__] thing in any
popular media because uh guys did you
know that you know gear five exists and
uh it's like the anime of that episode
is like coming out soon I would like to
keep it light on spoilers but I've seen
[__] massive exhibits of just like
this new Luffy form yeah they've just
built and I'm just like are people not
even trying anymore no like the exhibit
the anime exhibit thing in Japan they
just don't give a [__] yeah because
they're like because they assume that
everyone who's coming to these exhibits
just has caught up on everything like I
remember late I remember first thing we
ever talked about in this podcast
episode one I remember I was talking
about going to the attack on Titan
exhibit yeah right that feels like a
[__] decade ago but like I remember I
went there I'm not a margarita for
Attack on Titan anime only final season
hadn't even come out yet yeah and I was
like oh there's an attack on Titan
exhibit let's go check it out yeah I
went I got spoiled to [__] because they
literally show every single leg up to
the latest chapter in a frame and I'm
just like well great I just got [__]
said well I guess that's like me going
to like Van Gogh Museum be like [__] you
made another piece [__] that's like
going to the mango Museum
[__] what he's not alive
what the [__] that's like me going to
the Finland Saga exhibit and I'm like
what the wiki spoiled everything the
Wicked the Wiki's spoiling what happened
what's going on
dude
I don't know what happened because did
you know how bomb explodes at the end of
Oppenheimer didn't didn't see it didn't
even know they made a sequel It's coming
out
oftenham too no but like yeah like my
Twitter has just been like unfucking
bearable recently and a lot of that is
just to do with one piece fans they're
spoiled huh they got too much good [__]
yeah and I'm I'm sitting here being like
I am a one-piece fan I love one piece
it's one of my favorite anime series of
all time and now I'm just like [__] I
don't want to like one piece I I don't I
I don't want to be associated with as it
hasn't reached levels of Rick and Morty
though right it I think it's getting
better oh I think it's getting there
okay I I literally saw a tweet oh God
this morning that was literally like it
it was like part of like the paneling of
like gear five and there is like this
one this one panel of uh something that
Luffy does and it's not like like a
double page spreader it's like something
in the background that Luffy does in
this form and uh they're like this is
this is how this power Works he's in
just doing X he is literally like
adjusting the the molecules of his
bodies to do this and I'm like
[__] one-piece fan when they
see one panel when they call Oda like
God you know what I mean like Luffy
taking a [__] [__] this is like
foreshadowing to like an arc that came
five arcs later I'm like oh my God I'm
waiting for the one I'm waiting for the
one piece power scaling videos yeah I
guess that's what happens though when
you have such a long running show with
so many rewarding callbacks or mentions
of Prior information so you start to
think like he's got it all figured out
yeah well that's exactly what happened
I'm sure there's a good chunk of what
Oda writes where he just makes it the
[__] up yeah well that's exactly you
know what happened with like Naruto and
bleach as well like it went on for so
long that people just started to come up
with these like crazy fan theories that
neither of the you know creators ever
you know said was legit yeah and then
you just have people like [__] all
over the fan base because they're just
so hyperactive yeah and it's just like
it's just like a never-ending spiral and
now I feel one piece has gone to the
point again because there's no season at
least in the general consensus that is
on par or even above one piece that is
as long running as one piece so now
they're just in like an Unstoppable mode
they're like yeah I also think those wow
we're probably in a time where we see a
lot more negativity on social media in
general because it's rewarded more right
now like about Retreat culture so I
think I think it's probably a mixture of
that like wampy's getting more hype but
then also social media websites
rewarding or dunking or controversial
takes it's it's all it's all just like I
guess like sensationalized yeah you know
because like people are just like you
know by the time this is released
obviously the gear 5 episode is going to
to be released
um but uh half a monthly goddamn anime
huh and nobody got time for that anime
people calling this like uh like half my
timeline in terms of like one piece has
just been this is already the most
iconic transformation in anime of all
time Dragon Ball fans are dead don't
worry Dragon Balls time is over gear 5
Luffy is better than Super Saiyan Goku
and I'm just like what can you not like
something without dunking on something
else is that just not like is is that
not like a possibility here but I mean
Dragon Ball fans were already doing that
to their own fan base when like super
saiyan blue came out everyone was like
yo this is
Super Saiyan 3 ain't [__]
yeah I guess I guess I thought one piece
fans were better
I thought they were more civilized
[__] just can't like something
like did you see like no it's probably
all the Dragon Ball fans that were like
I'm not gonna watch super anymore hey
one piece and then they just migrated
over to the one piece fandom it's the
same fandom yeah because I saw like uh
Charlie got like a lot of at least here
on Twitter which I know is not real here
but you know it's sweaty people being
Twitter people yeah but I just it just
like blows my mind where he came out to
be like I like I finally like one piece
you know Charlie most critical finally
likes one piece he just doesn't like
Luffy okay and then a lot of people just
absolutely hated him for that and I'm
like how could you not like the main
character I mean I think for like half
at least a good chunk of the star Luffy
is the worst character
yeah but I mean Luffy and he's just like
like gone but like if God never grew up
I think uh I think Luffy has his own
charms as like a protagonist but he's
not my favorite character in one piece
but I can I can understand as a
one-piece fan why someone would not like
you know would not be the biggest fan of
Luffy you know I I see someone like
Charlie being like I'm I'm finally like
one piece and I see that I'm getting I
get excited I'm like this is a [__]
dub yeah man [__] yeah you don't like
Luffy okay understandable have a nice
day but yo
[__] yeah there's plenty of other
characters you can fall in love with you
know and then I see like a lot of One
Piece fans being like [__] [__] Charlie
[__] he's not a real one piece he
doesn't like one piece the right way you
know I don't like okay like shut the
[__] up [__] shut the [__] up
this is pissing me off so much yeah I
don't know it's uh it's one thing that
I've noticed and one thing where you
know there's been a few instances where
of like something and the fan base has
just made it a lot harder to like it as
well so are you convinced now or are you
calm contemplating to say that you're
not a one-piece fan anymore because of
that not that I'm not I'm not there yet
because I I do still really really
[__] like one piece yeah it's still
[__] great yeah but but you're not
gonna be as vocal about it I'm thinking
about it I'm I'm thinking I'm so happy
with me it's uh you know like you know
there was a good two seasons of Rick and
Morty before uh you couldn't call
yourself a fan I still enjoy Rick and
Morty even though it's kind of ass
I have fun with it it's it's it's fine I
do you think the quality has actually
gone worse or do you think it's purely
perception oh I think it has gone worse
right
but it was so good at its peak that I
think that it being worse than that
there's still a compliment as its
quality is still good yeah like I'll
take that over whatever the [__] Family
Guy is but I also yeah of course because
I feel like I don't know we don't get a
lot of dark dark humor animated stuff
yeah and you know sometimes the stuff on
Adult Swim is just a little too surreal
or a bit weird for me yeah and I'm like
I don't know so maybe it's a little two
were too odd for me
um and so it's nice to have something
like that and I feel like it's polished
it's okay yeah it's fine it's okay to
watch one one thing I thought about
recently was you know talking talking
about things that like fell off is it is
it just a me thing or has Pixar kind of
fallen off
oh I think it's not so much they've
fallen off I think it's just a matter of
we just grew up and we're not really
hearing about it
because name the best recent film
they've made
is Coco
what's that DreamWorks I think that
that's Pixar that thing's all right
maybe we should think they've released
after Coco
I want to guess too I think it's like I
think it's like four or five what the
[__] that phone went off
never mind scratch that how many have
there wait when did wait Coco came out
26 17 18 19 something like that it was
before the pandemic right
2017. what the [__] how many films are
really I'm pretty sure they release like
a
how many have they done since Coco to
now
another new one recently which was a
massive flaw dude well yeah I mean this
is like have you guys only been having
flops as well yeah yeah because do you
remember back in the day when we were
growing up pretty much every Pixar movie
just became like a classic you know
everyone looks at [__] like Toy Story
Monsters Inc The Incredibles [__]
Ratatouille up you know there's a reason
why they still get memed to this day
it's because they've stayed within our
Collective Consciousness because that's
how important you know you could
normally tell this is the new way to
tell if something is a classic or not
how often does it still get memes years
after this release Breaking Bad you know
sure that still gets memes and [__] like
that you know you don't see any Game of
Thrones memes anymore that just that
just shows you know but uh
what what no way wait since Coco there's
been 23 Pixar films
can you name all of them
oh
yeah I completely forgot holy [__] can
you can you name all the films they've
released
[__] ball that was a Toy Story 4 yeah it
sucks especially
yeah they fell off
the only one I recognize from there was
Toy Story 4. and that movie sucked
well I remember okay yeah I I remember
uh you know how high they released two
films
maybe they should have released yeah
maybe they should have done yeah I don't
know what happened with them because uh
like like I said a lot of their films to
me are Classics I'm trying to figure out
when exactly they fell off like was
there well I wasn't falling off I think
it's hard to they've had a lot more
competition you know elimination yeah
they're crushing it right now is
illumination competition they made the
Mario movie yeah I know uh do you know
how [__] profitable the Minions
movies were I'm not talking about
profitability here I'm talking about the
art of filmmaking Journey
like this is a masterpiece let's be real
the most popular animated piece of media
in like the past 10 years is [__]
minions don't say that don't say
that this is the reality I remember the
good old days where people look The Toy
Story and Incredibles and Monsters Inc
and those were the and those were the
Peaks that everyone talked about minions
they for better or worse they are the
what they they crush and
so they've been doing that and then
obviously the Mario movie and now
there's the other talks about the Zelda
movie or whatever yeah
um and then also DreamWorks is kind of
doing okay sometimes as the classic
DreamWorks formula of one bang a movie
four by one dog [__] movie they always
do this because they released uh Puss in
Boots which was have you guys watched it
no no [__] Puss in Boots are so good
yeah it's insane yeah you know I don't
even watch the first the second one's so
[__] good it's so you don't need to
watch this video you didn't watch the
first one do you know how much context
you've missed out Connor [__] off this
is like when John Wick said yeah
it's not when John Wick said yeah he got
excommunicado and you wouldn't know that
because you didn't watch the [__]
movie you did not get asked me to color
the point is the Puss in Boots too it
was an absolute [__] Masterpiece uh
and then they released teenage Kraken
I think kind of fell off oh Ghibli oh
they released that new movie yeah they
they didn't release anything about it
one poster for it and that was their
entire marketing I've heard it's like
good but I don't [__] know anything
about it because they never [__]
promoted and then the last couple of
moves before then were just like I I
know it can't fall off if you never fell
on yeah
I know this new movies
[Laughter]
I'm about to be that one piece
that movie yeah I know it because
everyone's like yeah it's good it's a
little weird yeah unless you know it's
meh cause they're saying it's weird
because I feel like typically always
struggles with like hey uh I mean it's
like we try to talk about yeah like to
me if it's just like a Ghibli movie I'm
just like without Miyazaki uh that's how
you know you know
sorry it's got him involved with it yeah
he came back out of retirement for the
fifth no no no what I'm saying is oh as
like a as like a Animation Studio yeah I
especially you know I'm not obviously
I've said this before I've never really
been a big fan of Ghibli movies but
especially Ghibli movies without
Miyazaki holy [__] no that's not true
there's a couple of like yonobayashi
films that are actually really really
good I mean like when Manny was there I
[__] cried to that that was a great
film that was no Miyazaki whatsoever and
then there are some Miyazaki films where
I'm like this is [__]
so yeah Turner sucks I I think that's
boring as [__] yeah but you didn't grow
up with it I was like what is this like
the [__] trains of uh
movies I was Spirited Away for the first
time I love this house
[Laughter]
it's all right and I was like
did you guess for all this stuff
like weird [__] was in that film do you
know how any how much weird stuff this
man this man was huffing something when
he made this phone no there's not enough
height it's just not enough IQ I guess I
just didn't understand everything I
didn't understand that the the I mean I
understood that the pollution was bad
because you didn't watch enough Rick and
Morty yeah yeah [__] I mean it's just
always so weird man it's like it's all I
I always I I do find it fascinating and
I'm glad that these movies exist where
it's like PG but [__] up it's like
every Ghibli movie is like yeah it's
just family friendly yeah certainly
friendly I wouldn't say princess
mononoke's family friendly yeah but I
feel like a lot of the films like house
is like it's a fun movie
because the trailers could easily sell
it it's like yeah Hal's got a castle
that moves oh boy it's an adventure and
then it's got a talking flame yeah he's
a scarecrow yeah and they make him
breakfast sometimes and then you get
into the second half of the film's like
war crimes oh okay all right guys man
it's melting in his room yeah this is a
family-friendly movie yeah
what the [__] why are we going with this
the fact that Spirited Away exists and I
think it's I mean what me watching any
Ghibli movie is uh I do like it as well
it's it's kind of like me watching any
like you know kind of like any Oscar Bay
kind of like nominated video no major
film where I'm like critically I'm like
this is [__] incredible personally
like personal attachment I'm like yeah
you know yeah I watched uh I don't think
I don't think it was maybe it was
oscarbate it felt like it uh 1913. do
you watch that the war movie or 1970 no
1913. is that the one by Christopher
Nolan no okay I don't think so that's
danker that's dunker oh yeah uh that's
yeah you're the one I'm about one yes
yes it's 1917 yeah yeah it's all one
shot and it was just like I actually
think I would prefer it if it wasn't all
one shot
and it's kind of weird because you
always I don't know it felt like a like
a thing that was like because it also
released at Peak Oscar season uh and it
just felt like it was trying to get the
like motion award Motion Picture award
for like best Cinema why is that always
they want like everything yeah like do
you think directors like sit in a circle
and it's just like guys I want to make a
movie that is going to get Awards World
War II okay like
God
F2 movie is just it's always War film
human drama there's no no other genres
allowed maybe there's a story in World
War II we haven't told yet I think
there's a lot of people especially older
people have very strong feelings about
it
yeah yeah yeah certain things
crowd or have some kind of or the
heroics of it I think there's a lot to
tap into there that makes for really
compelling stories yeah there is is it
easy to phone it in yeah but it's like
I think to people alive today there's no
other event that is like that big and
when are we getting the pandemic that's
what I want well that's not gonna be
good though [__] oh what if it's done in
one card
probably like no it'll turn into a
political thing I think like World War
II is not a political wow
you're all on the same side of thought
that it was you know we won good job as
well done Pat in the back what I'm
trying to say is like pandemic they'd be
like the Republicans be like no no
they're down here no like you know
obviously what I meant to say not not
yeah you didn't let me [__] finish my
point I knew I knew what your point was
but just out of context and I get what
you're trying to say about how to
contact just an example just saying uh
possibly like the big one of the biggest
Wars in all of human history I mean
that's uh in terms of like encapsulated
most of the countries in the world was
not political or the modern day outlook
of looking at the war is not a very uh
controversial political taste right it's
more like a yes yeah we beat the bad
guys let's celebrate let's make 15 movie
degrees about Saving Private Ryan yeah
you know and so I think that's you know
but that's why a lot of the really
interesting movies are ones that look um
taken non-perceptive of maybe other
sides or maybe ones that are set in
really interesting periods during the
war well well you're using stuff well
it's it's also like the interesting
debate of you know you look at something
like World War and you say it's like not
political and stuff like that well not
not how we no no in like the modern list
like I get what you're trying to say but
I guess the older I've gotten The more
I've kind of realized that the way that
history was taught in school is very
very different depending on which side
you're on and which country you were
born in right politics and the way we
look back is history is written by or
whoever like tells it whoever's well as
a saying is uh history is written by the
Victor yeah history is written by The
Victors well that's why like for example
one war film or I guess a set of War
films that I always thought was like
kind of underappreciated was the um the
Clint Eastwood War film where he told it
he made two different movies from two
different sites so like the Japanese one
was the lettuce to Iwo Jima film yeah
and then the English one was All Quiet
on the Western Front I think it's one of
those things
[Music]
it was in the other ones all from the
perspective of uh the American side of
things but like I feel though that was
really cool because it's like you got a
separate films that specifically you
know shown a light on both sides of the
war and then after you realize you watch
those two films it's like oh no one was
the winner everyone got [__] up
everyone was the culprit and like I feel
war movies need to do that a little bit
more just so it's like it's not just a
[__] like rat race of like yo yo
country one let's go America type of
thing yeah that's what I meant by the
political yeah the good versus bad
narrative is very easy to sell yeah it
is very easy but obviously there's a lot
more more to it more Nuance not just in
like movies but just in the way history
is told and taught because history is
never unbiased and the more I grow up
the more I realize that actually that
what that just reminds me
sorry when I first started in Sydney
right oh God I know the quote Yeah I
know you're gonna see it because because
he's [__] grilled her about this for
ages so when I first started dating
Sydney uh we were having like this I
can't remember what the debate was but
it was something to do with Wars okay uh
and then Sydney just goes yeah America's
never lost the war
and I'm like and I'm like uh I mean uh
what what do you think of the Vietnam
War and she's like oh no we won that
I wonder if that is like yeah she was
Sydney was talking Sydney just took away
that from her lessons
like according to her and I
I The more I've talked to uh Americans
especially you know especially uh people
and kids who do not grow in like the
Vietnam War era are at least uh the
conversations I've had in Wisconsin that
is that is definitely a very much
okay because I I at first I thought this
was a Sydney thing I'm like I'm suggest
a family yeah so I you know asked like a
lot of her families and friends when we
get drunk I'm like so so random question
who won the Vietnam War
and everyone's like we want it we killed
more people America yeah Freedom baby
and I'm like I know I'm like so wait
wait so you're telling me that you came
to a country for a certain purpose you
lost so many people because you know the
you you know you lost so many people and
you're like it's not worth this anymore
let's Retreat and they're like all right
it was a draw it's just like yo we
[__] clapped dude but you know how
many people we killed and I'm like oh
we're the our KD racer was higher half
of them [__]
also does is City aware that America had
a civil war you know where they also
kind of lost in some respect they lost
each other so yeah I mean obviously I
mean you can you can frame like you
could take any statistical point and be
like well they won like because I think
I think like I think in World War II
like on average like a German soldier
would would end up killing more people
than any other Soldier yeah uh whether
it's gonna matter so you'd be like yeah
the German soldiers are the best they
won yeah yeah like I think like it's not
a [__] Call of Duty
why are we comparing KD ratios well they
do like yeah but like also it's like a
meme where like uh obviously there's
like a common meme where it's like
France surrenders haha but I think like
pre-World War one and two I think of
like battles because of Napoleon France
had like the most wins to losses of any
country in battles
like I doubt the French like you know
like when they look back on like yeah
when we surrender they're not like oh we
didn't surrender we were actually the
bigger man like we we stepped down so
technically we won you know it's it's
easy to laugh at uh haha funny America I
think they win everything but like all
right we live in the one country where
they're gonna talk [__] about a lot of
the a lot of the bad history uh that's
true yeah you know in the you know it's
very questionable I think a lot of the
times what history is taught what is it
but then also it's like I guess the the
other argument be like what purpose does
it have to teach that and I think a lot
of the main idea is that you need to you
need to be taught this stuff to learn
from it yes of course history doesn't
repeat yeah if you're if you or your
country did [__] up things uh you
should learn about it like I think I
think in the UK we should learn more
about how maybe we didn't have the best
effect on everywhere we went to yeah
because we weren't taught any of that
[__] we're just like look at the map of
all the colonies aren't they great we
did such good work now don't worry about
what happened to them in modern day
times yeah like yeah genuine generating
my question at what age did you start to
like realize I wasn't taught all of this
stuff in school where
um you know I'd known that the British
colonies were [__] massive didn't
know why the British museum had all of
like the artifacts from all over the
world that would never returned you know
that was just something that was just
not taught in school about like well I I
remember we were just spawned there yeah
yeah it's just like all the
all the commercials
all of these things and we're just
putting it on display and uh that's just
a part of History man I remember we were
in we were in school and uh I took
history at a level yeah I love history
I've always been really fascinated by
history
um and uh we were learning about how the
UK uh was trying to have influence on
China was trying to take over and
obviously in China back when they've got
Hong Kong and all that stuff yeah uh and
China was refusing to buy any more opium
from oh the European Wars yeah yeah yeah
and they were like wow we took off India
we got all these puppies seeds we gotta
make oh you gotta sell it and so they
just started smuggling it in and getting
people hooked on opium and I know my
house like I was like 16 this time I was
like ah that doesn't sound like
something the good guys would do
not to be that guy but I don't remember
Superman drugging half a country just to
move some product that sounds like some
breaking badass [__] that the bad guys
would do I I maybe I'm crazy hear me out
and then they were like and then they
were like yes we they had to they sailed
these steamboats up that could just
destroy everything and the Chinese uh
Army can only just push barges on fire
in the hopes they would hit them I was
like that's been Fair
uh yeah it just seemed like I was like
ha there's more to this history things I
think that started like you know we'd go
to history uh class and I would go home
and just research more yeah because
Wikipedia would just tell you the facts
straight up and be like well I mean
whatever was sourced it wasn't always
accurate but it would close enough tell
you what was done you're like huh well
this stuff seems really as sketchy the
British did
oh they built railroads in these
impoverished countries wow good oh they
built only railroads to mines and not
any useful ones you can actually use and
they're all [__] and they can't be
maintained and they left and they left
it so fast that it started the Civil War
and there's been Warfare 50 years you're
like
we didn't do a good job we just finally
did the wrong thing or how we like you
know the British you know Johnny Harris
been a [__] 9 billion videos about
maps in Brazil and they would just draw
random lines of maps that would cause
Wars that are still going on today
um because we were so smart yeah it's
like well we've definitely caused so
many goddamn problems yeah I mean and
then you skipped out of there and you're
like we've never lost a war I I think
it's a good thing that the internet
exists now because I didn't didn't
really reach my Consciousness or like
the internet because in Orange because
now there's like so much misinformation
that you can read that's true well yeah
it's like people the fact that people I
mean not to you know could have that
it's very common now people just believe
that certain very very major historical
events didn't happen and that they can
believe that is mind-blowing to me yeah
uh and so
so telling of the power of information
on the internet and how disinformation
and misinformation can be so dangerous
yeah I feel like with with the way the
internet works now with all Freedom of
Information and everything it's kind of
like it feels like we got like the
monkey poor wish oh it's like you want
access to all the information in the
world that sounds amazing all the all
the information in human history
everyone's gonna get smarter but all of
it's wrong
I think some of my like you you really
like I'd say like modern history right
yeah I like modern history I'm like
really into like ancient history like
yeah I remember like I honestly like one
I I got I got into like I guess one of
like
the periods I think is most interesting
is like Chinese history actually yeah
and like Roman history and like you know
ancient Greece and stuff like that those
are cool because there's like literal
thousands of years that you can trace
back on yeah exactly so much happen like
like yeah like Roman history is like
Emperor chadius Maximus through games
and defeated the Persians and and then
like Chinese history
I mean it kind of kind of feels like
that you know
and then like Chinese history is just so
my firstborn Sony's history is like so
weird because it's like the amount of
times that China has just been broken up
as like a [__] country it's just like
oh there was a minor dispute about the
Farmland somewhere in China 70 trillion
people died in this war also the war
last 500 years I'm like what the [__]
was that and then they all came back
together in Hell dance and then they
came back together for one year and then
it broke up again and I'm like what what
the [__] is going on yeah it's it's yeah
history I feel like I've only gotten
more interested in history as I've grown
older I don't know I don't know if this
is an age thing because personally you
realize the most interesting [__] that
you can conceive of yeah is just all in
real life when it's happened at one
point or busy stories or crazy things
people have done yeah you're like oh my
God a real [__] person did that yeah
and I kind of get I kind of get that
feeling because I feel like a problem is
it's just how boring history is in
school I don't know I thought it was
taught in a very very boring way I
thought it was mad boring yeah like I it
didn't I don't feel like
I don't know for me I always find it
interesting so I found it like it's it's
like looking into another world but a
world that happened and existed and it's
gone did you have a good history teacher
though
um I think he was okay I think I was
just so fascinated in the the thought of
being able to tap into this knowledge of
periods that have gone and yeah that's
the true history yeah I just thought
that was so good like even learning
about like 1950s America felt like so
alien to where we were in the 2000s that
it was like what the [__] I can't
imagine like this time in this place
existing yeah and learning about that I
found I thought was so cool as a kid
yeah I think to me the reason I really
enjoy ancient history as opposed to like
more like modern history is because you
know I never really found World War II
or like kind of like the 1800s that
interesting just because it felt more
tangible than it than like ancient
history so it's closer to our proxy yeah
because like you you still see like I
don't know if the like when the last
World War II veteran is going to be
around for but you know you when I was
growing up there was still like many War
veterans and stuff like that so it still
felt like a tangible thing
um and I don't know I don't know why
maybe it's the escapism part of my mind
where I'm like oh ancient history that's
that's a that's a fake thing that didn't
really happen I I you're treating it
like a music
about how [__] up these dudes must
have been especially dudes because you
forget about it right I think we always
think about World War One World War II
such separate things yeah there's
there's like 30 20 years in between them
yeah yeah you know like
um there's very a good amount of people
who served in both yeah how [__] in
the head would you be after going
through that imagine going through it
once I think like guys we gotta do it
again yeah what they're just sit in
there all Carmen being like oh finally
it was worth it to come back and like
there's a sequel yeah what's there's
another one actually like the horrors of
like World War One and the conditions
and stuff back then like you know a lot
of a lot of big advancements were made
in medicine and there was like 20 30
years yeah uh between the the two Wars
and also weapons you know oh my God yeah
yeah I mean dude some of the shooting
like all the one was barbaric like yeah
chlorine gas and stuff like that like
imagine oh my God I mean even when you
look at like the Vietnam War as well
like just some of the [__] that some of
you know the sides were doing to each
other was just like I can't believe this
was in proximity not that long ago yeah
yeah I mean yeah and it's so easy to
think it just happened when our parents
were alive yeah it's crazy it's so easy
to think of those events as like
contained things where it's like a like
a match almost where it's like that was
the game you know and then but those
people do you know how it's so
fascinating to look into how these
people just functioned in society yeah
after there's no war yeah how do you
tell someone who's like 50 years old
who's maybe oh sorry like 60 years old
he's been in world of one and two how
are you like hey so yeah just just love
normally now like how do you how do you
how do you do that and so like learning
in the history of that and like reading
accounts of that I think it's just so
fascinating and so cool uh because it's
just like we live in an age where and
the reason why I like kind of modern
history so much is the level of
documentation and different sides you
can get it makes me makes you think like
how maybe ancient history or old history
must have been so biased by like one
source yeah
um no because you get so many different
sources nowadays no it makes me like
I've always found it interesting how you
know you think of
some of the most well-known figures in
some of their fields like I it just like
it's so weird to me to think that you
know [__] there was a time when
Aristotle and Plato were just like
hanging out and [__] like that because
like to me they just they feel like
fictional characters or just like you
know like like you know everyone in the
[__] Renaissance and [__] like that
uh or even just like famous artists like
Picasso and [__] like that you know yeah
you look at like you know some of the
most like famous Renaissance paintings
in the world and you just like look at
and you're like how did one person make
that like that is that is unheard of
like that's that's insane no wonder
they're famous yeah like think about all
the [__] like Leonardo da Vinci did yeah
not just like his paintings but like all
of his inventions and sketches like [__]
didn't he like invent the helicopter
yeah even before he was like one of the
first people to like come up with the
concept of it yeah it's not good it was
like it didn't work but it was a
foundation it was a foundation I'm not
good
but one one of my favorite uh historical
people I've I don't know if I've ever
talked about
I wish it was chattius Maximus his name
should be chadius Maximus but it was
like uh he was like a philosopher
diogenous or is it diogenes I don't know
sorry there's dialogue news I think it
might have never heard of this diagonies
yeah so you know Aristotle you know
Plato who has like famous philosophers
uh not many people know about diogenes
but he I feel like he's often he's often
called the father of cynicism and just
reading accounts about all of the [__]
that he got up to it feels like he was
the world's very first troll right okay
so
so one one of the things he did so Plato
[__] famous philosopher nowadays his
name is in history every history book
out there so he was apparently having a
lecture
and uh they were trying to Define what
what is a human right what what makes a
human and Plato at the time I believe
called humans featherless bipeds right
uh which which kind of like yeah we're
featherless and we're on two levels yeah
so diogenes was just like I gotta grade
up I got a great idea so what he does is
he takes the chicken he takes a chicken
plugs all the feathers out walks into
Plato's lecture plops the chicken on the
table and it goes behold man and
I I and I'm just like I I like you read
accounts of all this [__] and I'm just
like this [__] happens we look at
ancient Greece and like you know all of
this time where they fathered philosophy
and all this [__] but I'm just wondering
how much how much troll [__] actually
came down well I mean you know in order
for all of these like amazing
philosophical ideas to actually you know
keep their ground to the point where it
was taught for thousands of years
afterwards in history yeah I mean I'm
sure they went through a ton of trial
and error you know like I'm sure like
for every great idea there was probably
like you know aristol on a bad day being
like so does [__] actually smell bad or
is that just like our perception is huge
let's discuss it's like no let's grab
that from the history book this is
[__] let's get to the actual good
show right so like I can see why there
would have been philosophers out there
like uh diogen needs to just be like
yeah let me just like limit test this
like ridiculous idea that is philosophy
yeah and like see if it actually holds
any ground and I think it's because of
people like that that you know Plato and
Aristotle were like yeah what we said
was legit yeah we got this [__] right
here trying to like prove us wrong you
know one of my favorite memes I've seen
recently yeah it's like I don't know if
this is real or not uh or if this is
edited generally you can't tell but it's
like the Oppenheimer uh trailer being
shown and then just people cheering at
Albert Einstein like he's part of the
Avengers or some [__]
have you seen like the like Cinemas
react to like Avengers end game or some
[__] yeah yeah where you know you have
moments and then [__] you see Captain
America pick up the hammer and
everyone's like yo so yeah I don't know
if this is me but it's it's like a
shitty cam rip of I'm not sure if it's
the Oppenheimer trailer but it's like
it's like a really really serious
trailer and then Albert Einstein comes
on screen and everyone's like yeah it's
the goats it's the goat That's my boy I
saw I saw funny memes of people in the
front row of the movie
it's like the faces are all [__] up
why do they even bother selling tickets
in the front row they should not be
allowed to sell those tickets
it doesn't make sense yeah I don't I
[__] despise sitting in the front row
yeah I remember the first I I remember
distinctly the first movie I watched
where I sat in the front row uh because
all other tickets were sold out and it
was Star Wars episode three and I'm like
uh and I'm like maybe this will be a
good experience and uh so the movie
starts and the first thing I hear is
and I'm like [__] I immediately
regretted life I'm like I my eardrums
were [__] destroyed sorry sorry it's
not destroyed your ears but that's not
to mention like if you're in the front
row it doesn't even have to be an iMac
screen you're next like this yeah the
whole time and so after you finish the
movie your first thing isn't like wow
that was a great film and like talking
to your friends about it it's you just
going oh yeah [__] that was not worth
sitting at two hours to do this yeah
yeah you need a [__] chiropractor
yeah if you finish watching a movie like
that I should not be allowed to sell
those tickets no I don't know why
haven't you been sold in IMAX I don't
know why I still can't tell the
difference
of what I'm actually a normal Cinema
well IMAX is big yeah it's like there's
like no [__] difference because
you're big yeah I still I genuinely
can't uh maybe it's too big and I said
this once in an episode
like I I genuinely it doesn't it does
not change anything
yeah I've like every movie I've watched
in IMAX makes me uncomfortable because
the screen is so big I always feel like
I'm missing something I know it's
designed to be like this is going to fit
your peripheral vision and I'm like
there is so much information my brain is
trying to take in right now I don't
think I can process everything that's
like I can't I don't have the brain
capacity to care about my peripheral
vision right now I've got this [__]
right in front of me but it's all about
the immersion you know the immersion
just go to a 4D movie yeah that's more
immersive do you think VR movies can
ever exist or something oh yeah I think
it'll be a crap viewing experience yeah
I think ultimately your eyes just like
being far away from your screen because
I've tried watching movies through like
my VR goggle or like you know like uh
YouTube videos and stuff like that's
from my VR goggle and it does just
because I was curious to see if there
was a difference and I tried it out and
I'm like this is [__] like I I almost
prefer it if it was further away and
then I was like oh
that's what Cinemas are for I finally
understood at that point that's why
everyone wants a bigger TV but they want
to sit further away yeah exactly in
their house yeah exactly I it's kind of
like it there I guess that's like the
invisible fourth wall but I like
having a distance between the story
being told and uh what I'm being
presented because I always feel like
it's it's kind of like you're tricking
your brain into getting immersed in this
world but not not too much there's like
a safety net to there you know like I
couldn't imagine that's why I don't
think I could ever play VR horror games
I mean I hate horror games already but I
cannot I I think I'd literally go
through a heart attack if I played
something like Resident Evil in VR holy
[__] that sounds terrifying I get a
heart attack playing Resident Evil
regularly yeah exactly exactly yeah like
I'd probably I'd probably be that guy uh
jumping into like the television screen
that you see in like every Grandpa tries
VR for the first time video you know
that's that's an escape yeah yeah yeah
yeah
like I know it's fake but yeah even in
that just in horror I'm a [__] [__]
I don't know how people can enjoy movies
I'm right there with you yeah but it's
weird because I like I here's something
I really really like immersion immersion
is like so much immersion immersion
immersion is one of the most important
aspects for me when it comes to video
games and movies you know that's why I
like something like Final Fantasy 16
with a fully fully fleshed out world and
characters that I can just immerse
myself in the world to me that is almost
as enjoyable as the story being told
yeah yeah but that's the thing right is
that like I I'm right there with you on
that totally agree but like I feel
that's a different kind of immersion you
know like what you're what you just
described was an emotional emotion yeah
something like I am part of this world
whereas like VR games and VR movies or
like 4D movies they try and bring on a
physical immersion yeah which I feel has
still a long ways to go just because
it's doesn't really work for a lot of
people or it's not necessarily something
people want to be involved in it'll have
its Avatar moment I think so yeah I
think like if if they come up with like
a VR film or game or whatever where it's
like there is also so that emotional
emotion thrown into it then I think
it'll be a lot easier to actually get
physically involved in whatever it is
but as of right now it's there's very
few games that do that and uh the ones
that do are horror games like Resident
Evil which I'm like no thank you dog I'm
good but [__] sake the only genre that
it's really really really [__] good
in VR for immersion is Hurricane yeah
which is the one I don't play which is
the which is the one game that I don't
want so it's like right I'll play some
okay horror games on VR pretty fun yeah
kind of terrifying were you emotionally
your most into the I don't know what the
story was so no no
you're in like a mansion and there's
ghosts and [__] yeah but that's the
problem right is that like all these
like physically immersive games they're
not they don't give you the space to be
emotionally emotions like okay I got
scared very and I had a physical
reaction to it because there was a jump
scare that was right in my [__] face
library but at the end of the day once
the credits roll it's like well I don't
really much understand will care about
what just happened all I know is that I
just got jump scared by something yeah
fear and hunger VR let's do it
that'll be [__] horrifying how
terrifying is the game by itself
because what you said is that what
you've had the way you've described it
at least is it's terrifying because of
the gameplay aspects to it I was [__]
terrifying though too I mean there's the
enemies chase you down if they lock onto
you and it's gross yeah uh I mean
there's there's definitely some moment
where you're like oh
oh that's that's very disturbing yeah I
think disturbing and graphic is like the
two which I guess makes horror and they
think they both fall under horror yes
but there's no like jump scares or
anything like that which I appreciate
yeah
um I'm not normally into these kind of
Worlds but I know why it's been very
captivating yeah it's just refreshing
right it's great yeah it's awesome the
world's so interesting as well it is I
never care about see but that's yeah but
again that's like a great emotional
emotion where it's like oh I actually
care about this world and I and it feels
real yeah like I'm actually experiencing
through it and not just like hitting a
bunch of buttons to advance the story
kind of deal you know yeah
I wish there was more things to do with
existential horror I mean I've talked
about my love for lovecraftian horror a
lot but like existential horror is just
my favorite kind of it's kind of like
that
is it kind of like that yeah there's a
bunch of gods and [__] A bunch of weird
things you don't know [__] about right
story about people trying to become like
Gods yeah how that interacts with real
Gods okay
um
there's a ton of weird [__] Lovecraft
lovecraftian monsters that you're like
what the [__] and then you're like oh
this is the god of fertility you're like
what yeah I I got it and I got another
person VR fear and hunger yeah dude that
would be nuts I'd [__] myself yeah
you're in the [__] like blood uh
Cavern and then this [__] ogre starts
chasing you yeah [__] myself yeah just
dicks out get on a game do you know one
thing I've developed an irrational fear
for recently it's gonna sound so stupid
our context go on Infinity
in layman's terms why you are afraid of
infinity I think okay so I've you know
I've talked about being getting to like
a lot of like videos in terms like
physics and like I guess it just sounds
like you've watched one too many Vsauce
videos it's not it's not a Vsauce video
it's actually a uh it's actually a
documentary I saw that the BBC did like
on the concept of infinity because I've
it's fast I find it like fascinating
personally that
uh infinity as a concept is a something
that you can explain to like a
five-year-old you know but it's when you
really think about what it actually
means do you kind of like the more you
think about it the more you fail to
grasp what Infinity actually is like
what's the biggest number you can think
of like what's what's the biggest number
you can at Googleplex a Googleplex yeah
like you think of like a Googleplex
which is what's what's the uh Guy what's
the exact definition
[Music]
is 10 to the power of 100 yeah Google is
10 to the power of 100 so it's one with
a hundred zeros on the end right
um so if you think about a Googleplex
right you cannot even write if you if
you take the one and put every zero on
an atom in the Googleplex you will run
out of space in the entire observable
universe before you can literally before
you can even write out a Googleplex yeah
and that number is a [__] tiny number
compared to like Infinity yeah right it
it is Tiny it's it's Infinity as a
concept if you really really think about
it you know the biggest number I can
think of off the top of my head and this
is now this is how you know I've gone
down a rabbit hole is is this concept
called tree three right and if you even
try to fit three if you try even try to
fit tree three into the observable
universe if you take the smallest unit
of measurement in the observable
universe Plankton which is a plank
distant and divide that in the entire
space of the universe
you will have to compress like you could
you have to compress information so
densely that you will turn the entire
universe into a black hole
[__] and still that is a tiny [__]
number and like the more you think about
it the more you're just like
holy [__] this is yeah yeah it's
infinite right it's easy to say it's
infinite but the more you think about it
the more you like
the more you like holy [__] this is this
is something that you cannot even come
close not even not even minutely
comprehend what Infinity actually means
and then I think about it and I'm like
[__] me that is terrifying just to think
that humans have invented a concept that
can make ourselves feel so insignificant
and yet it's like and yeah uh [__]
child can understand so what does the
number scare you sorry what is the
number scale I think it's the concept
it's the con why does it scare you sorry
why does that scare you it's just like
you just makes you realize it's because
it's like he's gonna try and write the
number out gone it's not gonna happen
it's it's the concept it's the cons it's
the it's the like I said that's the
that's kind of like the feeling of
existential horror that I love it's it's
the concept of it right this makes sense
because it's probably why you play
genshing so it doesn't have any [__]
gotcha pulls you do that that is [__]
lovecraftian horror man I know I know
how you feel because I got into that
similar well I got into that similar
kind of rabbit hole a while back yeah I
was like what are you guys doing well
because I because I watch a lot of like
math and like physics videos yeah I'm a
[__] nerd yeah but I I remember like
this will blow your mind God think about
it like this there are
an infinite amount of numbers right like
finite numbers one two three four five
six seven yeah there are the same amount
of infinite numbers between zero and one
yeah
and because if you get if you're trying
to write out right zero to one yeah
what's the next number that comes after
zero zero point zero zero zero zero zero
zero so it's just an infinite number of
zeros and then somewhere at the end
there's a one not on my calculator
do I know it's something even more
[__] gone [__] mind blown are we
giving each other Infinity yeah yeah we
are we are giving each other infinity
facts well Connor loses mine right now
go on there are Infinities that are
bigger than other infinities yeah I know
I've seen it at this yeah they have like
the infinity to the power of two
Infinity yeah yeah you're like okay
which is still Infinity I'm I'm like
it's gotten to the point where
mathematics has evolved to a point where
we can give ourselves well they have to
figure out what the odds were of Hunter
Hunter for being finished
[Music]
that's a that's a number lower than uh
any number that's ever been written in
the in the [__] Universe we can wait
till the end of the universe until she's
late yeah no I want a [__] horror
movie around the concept of infinity
they'll be [__] that sounds like a
really [__] M Night shy actually that
would be it sounds like
it already in those shamlai presents
Infinity I'm not funding this movie no
one else is housewife finds out that
she's uh in in infinite a number away
from [__] finding a husband and
but yeah anyway uh that was uh trash
taste existence crisis yeah I'm feeling
you enjoyed it uh we are going to be
getting drunk on the next one so okay
expect more existential courses
expect uh even Wilder talks out of the
next one
if you want to support the show look at
all these patrons though they love
Infinity yeah give us your favorite
Infinity fact in the comments
make it so we have
but hey if you like to support the show
hit on that patreon patreon.com trash
days also follow us on Twitter send us
memes on the subreddit and if you had
our face listen to us on Spotify and we
will see you guys next time hopefully
not an infinite time away oh my God oh
my God okay oh my God okay bye
[Music]
thank you